let's move on here so a little update on
the whole
uh brennan schaub situation
this guy homeless lion
made this video um and in
i think really quickly this video was
was taken down
it's kind of a super cut of a bunch of
it's called brendan
brennan chauver coming for you it's a
super cut of all his stuff and again ben
pixels
uh took it down now i want to say the
same thing i said yesterday we're going
to [ __ ]
you could sue us i guess if you want to
right but
what we're doing now specifically what
we're doing is this is
100 fair use we're providing commentary
uh this is a very small percentage of
our show but we have to play it you
can't just make stuff disappear joe
it doesn't work that way so this is the
original video that was deleted from uh
homeless lion who's homeless
youtube.com homeless lion the homeless
cat
thank you thank you for booking this a
homeless cat
it's kind of a cool thing is brian why
is brian gallon
turning into a an amalgam
of colin quinn and joe matarys yeah
right yeah it's like you know [ __ ] i
don't know
just cheating on his wife or whatever i
don't know
brandon shop we're coming for you gonna
get attacked online you better watch
yeah they're coming for you bro oh no
bring it bro you don't know what the
[ __ ] gonna happen no
absolutely they love it though they love
their passions
and if you talk to that they come at
they might as well make movies and tv
shows
while they're at it i don't think it's
gonna be that easy though
i don't know come on eddie i'm scared
you know whenever rogan has his hangout
shows
with all these people you could really
tell how stupid his friends are
not that joe is smart i don't think he's
a brain or anything
but he's reasonably intelligent compared
to the people he hangs around with
well yeah he wants to be the smartest
guy in the room he [ __ ]
surrounds himself with dummies right
which is not a good thing that's not a
great
way to be in life you end up with a lot
of brendan schaubs in your life
like i welcome smarter people than me i
want more talented people than me i want
somebody to come along and me and royce
can just take a piece of their action
and get them established [ __ ] i've
already said franchise franchise the
show
yeah man [ __ ] that [ __ ] but not not i
don't feel threatened by smarter people
i just try to find a way to tax them
yeah
get them into a contract and then i'll
be like hey you run wild go be bigger
than me that's great
just throw me a little something once in
a while
what what what he's doing better than us
he's doing better than us
for now did you watch the special anyway
uh
i did not talking about shop special i
don't watch a lot of comedy tim dylan
good answer timmy i don't i don't watch
an answer i never watch comedy
by the way i love louis j gomez yep um
because all of these comedians are
getting really
and they're all running interference for
each other none of them will criticize
each other anymore
and luigi gomez is one of the few that's
like do you see a special
yeah that's a good answer like so you
know what i mean like luigi gomez will
never
be like i don't know if i could bring
this up because of politics he doesn't
give a [ __ ] he get milo on he doesn't
give a [ __ ]
pretty funny what does it feel like
having a showtime special
i don't know i feel the same a little
more stressed out a little stressed out
yeah yeah stay away from them comments
on
everywhere there's a whole deal with all
that stuff man you put it out
you watch it you hate it you get better
forces you
force you to work no no no no no no
no he didn't even tell him hey it's good
no that's him going like ass
get you'll get him next time you're
right but no that's not how it goes
comics don't get comics don't get better
by failing at a showtime special by the
time a comic has a showtime special
their material has been deemed good
enough
to get a show you know what i mean like
you get better by going on the road
staying in [ __ ] boise idaho in a
motel 6. you know what i mean like
actually putting the work in and growing
your act
not in what one year taking the stage
and telling stories and doing ah me
chinese jokes
and then you get better when you fail at
a showtime special no
hbo special showtime specials used to
actually mean something right
it used to be like man this person's got
their [ __ ] together they got a really
good act
they're [ __ ] killing all over america
let's give them a showtime special
it's not like ah you know it takes you a
couple hbo showtime specials to really
get the hang of it
don't worry brendan look we'll we'll do
it you'll kill him at the next uh
showtime special
and if you don't hey we'll get him at
the next showtime
how many showtime specials is he getting
out you watching what's the last time i
saw maria bamford on a showtime special
when you throw her [ __ ] phone
seriously
he's just christ would rather watch her
for [ __ ] an hour than brendan shout
for 10 minutes
eat it you get better forces you uh
let's show ours oh this is the scene
what's your work
i [ __ ] hate everything i do there's
no there's no getting around it
you're gonna hate it you hate hearing
yourself right the editing is painful
man
the worst but you'll get better you just
take
the some of the criticism to heart
understand what people are saying for
sure just uh
[ __ ] keep on keeping on oh that's
awkward
you felt that one do you feel that
awkwardness keep
keep on keeping on imagine you just
[ __ ] a chick right
and she says to you don't worry you'll
get it next time you keep on keeping on
you wouldn't be able to you wouldn't be
able to get your dick up for a week
i mean you'd be so depressed over that
keep on
keeping on made me feel so awkward
understand what people are saying for
sure just uh
[ __ ] keep on keeping on i'm happy
about it i just i i don't know
by the way i don't know why because you
know i i'm watching this
this is so far this is 100 a fair use
fit forget what we're doing because
we're even adding another layer of fair
use
this guy got [ __ ] by ben because this
is per but there's music you're editing
different stuff it's
it this is a 100 percent fair use video
that's going on
i just then took it back that was i
don't know why i said that
and and then brian uh or brendan was
like yeah i think i had a showtime
special once
like when he said a showtime social once
i went
that's what they're going to say about
him
[Laughter]
that's fine oh [ __ ] that's funny from
workaholics and that wasn't even
malicious you could just tell eric
griffin's one of those guys that just
is always trying to crack a joke and
that just kind of like flew out
i love them workaholics
and boy and i think that's why i have
thick skin now and like haters or social
media or
anything doesn't really get to me then
why are
every why are any videos criticizing you
being taken off the internet
also i don't understand like which one
is the kid right because
uh this looks like the fighter and the
old man okay well
look it's what is the reference to i
don't know
i don't really watch it can someone
explain to me what
the fighter and the kid i i don't know
what that means
is brian callan the kid i don't i don't
know i don't watch anything it's a very
few shows and you know but you're like
brendan schaub the fighter and the kid
and then like it's the fighter and the
kid and brian gallon
that was too wordy for the see the
problem is the rss feed it was too wordy
for it
so they had to keep buying california
somebody explained that to me because
it's it's a terrible name for a show
and why do they have their breaking two
shoes on the table
what's this setup here that he loves
sneakers bro oh
all these la comics go over there and
they become
sneaker guys like right it's all this
they they all do whatever kanye tells
them to
basically get a bomb threat
what and the indie police were like they
were actually really on it
were they worried you were going to bomb
flat thick skin now
he's a child he really is a child
like i don't know if it's all the
punches in the head or maybe he's just
this way
but he kind of has the mentality of a
child sometimes especially when he's
getting picked on
he's like why do you see how tight my
jeans are why are you making fun of me
all right so i am the highway here just
pointed out that
it's the kid is brian calvin that's his
nickname yeah he's a kid yeah he's
like a 60 year old man yeah the kid
six year old kid but he he looks like
an old man come on that's a good burn
dude
there's a brandon shop told me stories
like he
to people because you know he's a big
guy
to stand up and somebody went up on
stage at the improv and he said um
he said who the [ __ ] he looks like
a producer that you have to suck his
dick to get the job
no he looks like the guy who's dick you
have to suck
to even get the meeting with the
producer okay you're right yeah he works
for the purdue he's not even the
producer he's the guy that's like yeah i
can get you in with harvey
you're right people because you know
he's a big guy
and it looks like if i if i said to
myself hey uh bali song i need you to
draw
mark ruffalo but reimagined as a 1930s
propaganda cartoon well there he is this
would be what bali saw withdrawal
right i think it's just who is this guy
he's so boring
he's a big guy and
and somebody went up on stage at the
improv and he said um
he said who the [ __ ] is that guy like
you can't be that handsome
and [ __ ] like start just tearing into
him like for being
like being a fighter too yeah this is
not for you yeah
well it was eric griffin was it yeah
yeah he was just [ __ ] around
yeah it was just like that's what you
say you know the guy goes up and he does
stand up and he's
got this perfect haircut you're like hey
[ __ ] you
is that right though yeah but you mean
eric griffin's right yeah yeah of course
he's 100 right you can't be
like i've said this for years you can't
be and this was the best advice i ever
got from somebody
when they told me i was suffering from
the same problem he's like you're trying
to be
funny and you're also trying to be cool
and
you can't have both you got to decide if
you're going to be funny or if you're
going to be cool guy
funny at least make some money and get
shows and it was like
you know i learned that you can't be
like yeah yeah look at this
fat [ __ ] yeah look at this nice try a
foreigner like it's just like you just
come off like an
[ __ ] right it's not the same
how do you get there i
i know some bald [ __ ] dudes are
slanging dick out there
look at data white rogan
i love this sorry this is one of my
favorite freeze frames here
look at that he look at that
and we've all had that moment in life
not as big and
publicized and as much of a blunder but
you've had moments where you dry
snitched on someone accidentally and
immediately went
right here this face has hello darkness
my old friend going
through his head best example that was
years ago i i had a roommate when i
lived in miami
and uh my buddy was cheating on his
check right
with his ex-chick and he told him that
always worked he told his ex chick that
they were going to get they were back
together basically
and that they were dating now but he
still lived with his current chick
so his ex chick came to town one night
and hour one afternoon i was working
night so i was sleeping on the couch
and uh she came and woke me up and i
remember she woke me up and i was like
i said the current girlfriend's name
because i thought his girlfriend
oh no
that that was a friend and child moment
rowan and i tried to run i
really tried to clean that up but it was
and then i was like nah it's
chick that i'm i've been [ __ ] with
yeah
but it was like i it wasn't my fault i
was dead asleep
i wasn't even in my room like i came
home drunk
that night from work and i just was like
on the couch and i got hey wake up and i
was like felicia
and she's like who is flesh and i was
like
oh it's my
can i get some coffee let me have a
cigarette we'll talk about this like i
was so i felt so bad
that's it jesus i love that
that's it ew you want to see it yes
yeah show that to brenda but tell him to
shut the [ __ ] up about it
brandon sheeb is a [ __ ] [ __ ] and i'm
gonna say that out right now
and [ __ ] that guy who's that it's bobby
lee
that's bobby lee that's bobby lee bobby
lee
i've seen clips him talk about brandon
schaub in a little more positive light
[Laughter]
brandon sheeb is a [ __ ] [ __ ] and i'm
gonna say that out right now
and [ __ ] that guy yeah but hold up hold
there is a vibe coming out of this too
where he's despised
by almost any of the real comments well
yeah i mean because they had to
eat [ __ ] for a lot longer and and eat
[ __ ] and eat [ __ ] and then now
it's the mistreatment it's when the mist
came from from mtv
and they made him change in the [ __ ]
hallway like that's what it is the
difference is that miz actually got into
it and worked hard and became better
and now he's the guy in the locker room
that people look up to and right they
like them is because
but he had to go do every shitty uso
tour every event he didn't want it he
became the guy it's like i'm gonna
you don't want to go to that signing and
then that [ __ ] backstage meet and
greet i'll do it
fine i'll go do the make-a-wish i'll do
that like he
ate a lot of [ __ ] and people went okay
you know what man even after our shitty
we treated him and locked him in the
hallway he did all that like
and now people are like wow he's
respected this is gonna be a hall of
famer
i i have a feeling though that this is
gonna be a harder one to turn around
because i don't think brendan shaw has
the attitude no
or the work ethic that that mike nizanon
has
uh so i i just think that people are
starting to go like
[ __ ] this guy you know what i mean like
look
there's also reasons why you know you
see
guys like brody stevens themselves and
you know i read that story and i
literally almost choked up when i was
reading it because
they did a thing about brody stevens
and they talked about like they very
described in great detail
the scene of him killing himself and how
like he lived in a studio apartment in
la
and he had like uh one of those walls
that i had when i was like 24
of just posters and flyers and pictures
of me with like
guys i've done shows with and like it
was like a shrine to this
failing at being famous and it was like
sad you know what i mean
and then you got guys like that who see
a brendan child pull up in a porsche and
get to park in the cool kid parking lot
which bobby lee was talking about
in another video that there's like a
special lot that they'll let like
the store regulars park park there yeah
brendan shout from day one just [ __ ]
come and park there like he was always
this
chosen one and you know you imagine
being a brody stevens and you're doing
your [ __ ] hundred dollar hosting gigs
on the weekends and you're just trying
to get you know and it's like you're
just a house [ __ ] you're the [ __ ]
good for bobby lee though by the way for
[ __ ]
outing this guy because you know bob lee
is another one that would be on rogan a
couple times not as much as shaub or
whatever it is but
um good for bobby lee it falls into
other
[ __ ] like video games cartoons comic
books nerd culture it's like stuff that
you enjoyed when you're a kid
and these guys embrace it deep into
adulthood it's fun
it's fun for them i get it i don't mind
it me
i'm just a homeless cat man
wow so whatever that was at the end
well they paid him on cameo to do it i
get it
um so this
is uh brendan's uh
what would you call it this is uh
brendan is about you know brendan
made a made a a good fall it happens i
mean he made a faux pas if you will
and uh he wants to make it right so here
it is the uh
explanation that nobody asked for
that joe rogan probably didn't ask him
to do
uh here it is the pregnancy you don't
like to smoke a drink for a second he's
like dude
i always do it just takes the edge off
i'm like he has been doing comedy for
35 years this guy knows what he's doing
he's one of the best
to ever do it so let me do a shot with
him
do a shot i won the best sets of my life
and i'm like well
i gotta keep doing this gotta keep the
trend going nobody with cauliflower ears
will ever be a good comic
went from one shot now it's a double now
that's a double
one cauliflower here like he does and
then imagine
also not having a good uh legacy as a
fighter
yeah like that's the worst thing is that
you got out of fighting and you're not
going to be remembered as a good one
but you will always have that
cauliflower here
before every set you have three sets a
night we're going sizzler
it's not a good way no i'm usually fine
man
it's usually one double and then i'm
good so if you see me doing stand up i'm
drinking
one double yeah i'll tell you what's not
a good idea this is how i'm gonna segue
into this
i think it's not a great idea
so let's see this explanation i can't
wait to see someone hand them a shovel
is to quote anything i say off
a a number of the three shows that i do
between below the belt for showtime
fire and the kid brian the kid count or
especially
king and the sting with fellow comedian
and
very close friend of mine theo vaughn
to quote anything or to cut anything
that i say out of king this thing which
is a pure
comedy entertainment i'd say the show
it's even hard to call it a podcast
the way that it's a podcast it's called
the podcast the youtube show
yeah that thing is produced it is
basically a tv
a high functioning tv show put on you
can't even say
functioning so how are you in a high you
know what you are
yeah here's what you are you're a high
functioning
you know like you could drive a car it's
impressive
but the to call anything that you do
some sort of
it's all you know what this reminds me
of the old ona it's
theater of the mind no it's not
what are you guys doing foley work back
there yeah you guys talk [ __ ] on a show
it's not it's not pretty it's a youtube
show with two camera angles you're not
writing a script
there's no script for that show on
youtube
if i told you guys how much a thing is
to make it blow your mind
if that show caught how much it is to
make
how much money are you spending on this
youtube show
look i get that there's plenty of shows
that have more money than us and look
better than us
i get it but there's when you're doing a
youtube show isn't it like
a level of diminishing returns like the
most expensive part will be the cameras
and the mics but that's like a one-time
expense right you buy those cameras you
buy those mics
maybe you pay a producer maybe you pay
one producer but again
why would you do that but fine if you do
that that's fine
how much money can it cost it's two guys
talking [ __ ] on a microphone
it's unbelievable how much they lie and
[ __ ]
oh yeah then how about how high quality
they are that's what that thing is
that is theovonne a one of the greatest
comics in the world
and let him get on with his list of lies
right he's
he's not though one of the best alive
even if you like theo vaughn there's
people that like him to say he's one of
the best comics in the world
even theo von fans are gonna be
screaming at us calling us fat losers
later when we clip this
um even theo vaughn fans would have to
go okay look he's not
one of the greatest comedians around and
my dumb ass
trying to outdo each other and the way
it works you haven't listened to it
if you've just seen a headline that i'm
gonna address right now
which i can't believe i'm addressing
this but it
i trust me brennan
nobody can believe you're addressing
this instead of letting it die down
you're making it worse has to be done
because it's affected a close friend of
mine so
the way that show works is fans submit
videos that show is generated and
created
for fans and is made possible by fans so
there's like
and viewers like you what are you doing
a pbs pledge get to it brendan
rip my drip people send in uh pictures
of them wearing
clothes or flop my aunt it's their aunt
or babysitters or moms of
and we talk about all of this stuff i've
haven't watched your show
but even him describing the show makes
me not to want to watch this show well
that's true we have watched some shows
we watched like clips of making fun of
each other but never sat down and
watched an entire episode right
why would you but no but these sound
doesn't don't these sound like morning
zoo bits
flaunt my aunt pimp my hoe like would
you wore
roses that where the roses next
what they look like or there's
relationship advice
and this is which brings me to this next
uh
kind of segue into why i'm even
addressing any of this
on last week's podcast on king the sting
with theovan i
a gentleman who was losing his hair sent
in relationship advice says i'm losing
my hair man
i'm worried about shaving my head i'm
worried i'm not going to get chicks
anymore
my dumb ass i say a lot of done things
and we know
i take credit for it and i own it man no
you don't you don't talk
he is framing himself to be a person
that he's never been or ever acted like
i take credit no you don't
brendan we've dealt with you before with
that documentary of making fun of you
and criticizing you you had it
completely deleted from the internet
like four times
and but the when i have a problem with
it is when it affects very close friends
like joe rogan
uh who has to deal with some sort of
media frenzy now because they misquoted
me
there's not a media okay another lie
here
has there been a media frenzy or there
because media frenzy implies that cnn
and fox
there's no media frenzy by media frenzy
you mean us two
and a couple people on reddit yeah
there's reddit people youtubers is that
a media frenzy
when i say miss quoted me i assume
everyone knows the context that i'm
talking about because i'm talking to my
very good friend theo vaughn
we both know joe rogan i live in that
context
i'm a [ __ ] there's millions that that's
that
please clip the emma [ __ ] show this
isn't bragging it's one of the biggest
podcasts in the world there's a ton of
people watching
not everyone knows my relationship with
joe not everyone assumes my little sheep
with dana wyatt or theo
i have no idea when we're in the context
of that show
i'm in this little student it's me and
theo talking i gotta do better i've been
doing podcasts way too long
to let something like this affect so
this gentleman who's losing his hair
goes
um hey man i'm losing my hair i'm
worried i'm not gonna get chicks anymore
something to that i forget
his exact comment shout out to that guy
um i forget his exact comments but
in general it was i'm losing my hair
what should i do and i go
man don't worry about losing your hair i
know guys who are killing the game
who are slang in dick now if you just
hear me say slang and dick
and this is the way people took it which
i
looking at the clip i get how you take
it away no the guy was specifically
asking about love life about getting
laid about having sex
so when you say slang and dick you can't
change what slang and dick means
you're [ __ ] a lot of people you're
[ __ ] a lot of chicks you're slanging
dick
that's what that means you're gonna tell
me you joe and eddie bravo have an
inside joke about slang no you don't
you're lying
you're a [ __ ] liar and this makes it
worse
slang and dick means [ __ ] girls
sleeping with many women
that's not what i meant by by at all but
i can get how you get to that conclusion
when you just watch i could understand
why
no no no let me i could understand why
because sling and dick means [ __ ] a
lot of chicks right
so i could see why when i said sling and
dick you guys would take it to mean the
thing that it literally means
i could you could i could see why you
would do that
you're confused what i'm saying is is
i meant the phrase as something it
absolutely doesn't mean
are we clear no i have a lot of
questions here case closed
i have a lot of questions here so people
took what you said literally because you
said something literal yes
okay makes sense you're right the clip
my contact is saying slinging dick what
clip and by the way
if the context was you joking so let's
say it was there's so much cleanup
yeah why was the episode taken down and
why was that that section cut out of the
podcast
if if it was this the this the show that
you spent so much money on you scrapped
an entire episode
and edited a podcast because
of a line that clearly you were joking
see that's the thing brandon you can't
have it both ways
if you're [ __ ] up you're deleting it
fine but now you're trying to say no no
no but even though i'm deleting it it's
also because i didn't mean that
but i meant by that and this me correct
it now
so there's no miscommunication there's
no blurred lines
yes right i did not mean this totally
gonna make it better yeah this is gonna
make it way better he's
cheating on his wife he said the thing
about doing politician finger
he's doing he is politicizing such a
phony
he is not cheating on his wife
there's no blurred lines i did not mean
joe rogan is cheating on his wife
you think joe wrote when they lie do you
think joe rogan wanted him to say
the phrase i don't think joe rogan is
cheating on his wife
can i steal a page out of the book of
mike perbegula sure
i think if you asked joe what brendan
should have said
was nothing except what he did say
was whatever the [ __ ] this is joe rogan
is one of my closest
dearest friends doing politician finger
it makes you seem dishonest and nervous
it does right he never talks like that i
wish everyone had a friend like joe
rogan did you steal twenty dollars out
of my wallet i would never steal
twenty dollars why are you doing bill
clinton though
i talked to him damned every day even i
would never
never ever
do anything anything to
to bring any sort of harm his way
or hate or attention especially on his
wife his wife and my wife are friends
that is ridiculous which means his wife
was texting your wife and going what the
[ __ ] is wrong with your stupid husband
and brendan
are you also slang and dick out there
when you're doing your little tours
if i were a batman royce you [ __ ]
[ __ ] the you're saying the quiet part
loud you [ __ ]
if i were he's what he's doing if i were
a baton man
i'd say he slangs just as much if not
more dick
than joe rogan does because he's younger
and he's still got his hairline and
stuff you know right
yes and that's on me that's on me i got
to do better
not talking about my personal friends
like that
back to this when i say guys slang and
dick
what i meant is joe and i reference
three guys
if i think i'm i haven't seen the clip
in a long time he's been panicking
three he's panicking yeah cause he's
lying if you explained any situation
like this i'd be like i got dude i want
to have your back here but
you're being a panicky pete what did you
do what why are you getting so agitated
right like
just go no that's not what i meant i
mean i can see why you meant it that way
it's kind of dumb of me
and boy did i really step in [ __ ] but
yeah that's not how i meant it so we're
just going to move on but he's like and
and
i i i i actually pointed out last night
on nightwave that he's talking like dave
meltzer
you notice when dave meltzer never gets
to the end of his point yeah he's always
like
yeah so you know aj uh aj styles
they're gonna put the belt on him at
summerslam uh make him champion again
you know and uh and aj
you know we work very hard uh but the
feeling in the locker room right now
um is that aj is and and you know you
know like when he was in japan you know
you know how it was when he was in japan
oh my gosh get to it
so the you know so the feeling in the
locker room generally speaking
when it comes to like with vince because
you know what he says you don't stop
that's every dave meltzer phone call on
on figure four and you're like jesus
dave get to the [ __ ] point
three guys joe rogan bald guy slang and
dick crushing it one of the best comics
in the world
biggest podcast on our biggest show we
talk about just shows so when you talk
about
even though the guy specifically didn't
did guy didn't say
i want to become a successful podcaster
he didn't say i want to have a
successful show the guy that sent the
question and said he wanted to get laid
we're to believe we're to believe
us plebs are to believe that what you
meant was
it's because he's successful on doing a
podcast and not because
he's [ __ ] chicks we're to believe
that yes
that's what he meant he's slinging dick
bro
in the metaphorical sense
what about howard stern he ain't [ __ ]
compared to joe rogan you want to talk
about any show you watch on tv
it ain't [ __ ] compared to joe rogan
listen it
he's done he's listening to him he's got
a he's he's now sucking brogan's dick
because he [ __ ] up with daddy
that's slang a dick that's killing the
game dana white
another successful bald dude who [ __ ]
allegedly [ __ ] ronda rousey and a few
other people
allegedly this is alleged oh and that
was when he
yes oh that's i remember that story yeah
that was
sing allegedly yes that it was while
they were
correct that guy
so cru slang and dick what you meant was
[ __ ]
you should have said nothing this would
have gone away quicker
do you okay here's the thing we said in
the yesterday's show we when we found
out the little [ __ ] goth that you had
we weren't we weren't even gonna talk
about it
because like yeah joe rogan [ __ ] other
chicks we figured he's [ __ ] biggest
star in the world
that's not that's that's what you do
like that stamina arrangement i'm sure
or whatever nobody care we were
honestly told my god i'm going to talk
about the show who gives a [ __ ] but then
the story shifted from it being rogue
into being what a [ __ ] idiot you are
and having videos taken down in videos
deleted
that's what that this became this became
you
being an idiot now honestly
we didn't have this on the prep for
today again this is another chance where
this could have gone away
the pewdiepie thing if anything got you
off the hook yeah but it would have been
all the big news
instead what you did was you had more
people's videos deleted
and then you went on here and
backtracked something where what you
should be doing is saying nothing at all
you are the dumbest person who's ever
gotten a showtime special
you're the you you're the stupidest
person ever allowed
to be on a stand-up stage you're not
funny people laugh
because they know you ah weed you're so
crazy oh my chinese we get it man
you're not a funny dude all right you're
you're the worst
you do three podcasts and you're the
worst part of every one of those
podcasts
you're the worst part you're not funny
you're not insightful
your life stories are either made up or
you've never really struggled
and you're like you're a good-looking
guy you've never had a problem picking
up chicks
but you're also not funny and you've
just been given this fame and now you're
gonna sit here and suck rogan's stick
because you're afraid
you're afraid of not being invited back
on i think the reason that he was on
rogan even after this happened was
because he was scheduled to be on before
he said this
and rogan's would make it look even
worse if he had him back on
i have a feeling you're going to see him
a lot less on that part
my guess maybe i'm wrong you're going to
see him a lot less on that podcast
i think joe gets a piece of this guy
though so i think financially he's going
to want to keep
yeah you might be right i don't know
we'll see
who is slang and dick aka killing the
game
not meaning he is sleeping with many
women slang and dick could be saying a
dick to your wife
no no that's not what it means
that's not what it means you are making
this
up you are making this up as you go
so full of [ __ ]
could be just in general kicking ass
that's not that's on me slinging dick to
99.9 of the people
outside my circle of friend means
[ __ ] other girls cheating on your
wife we're now five minutes into an
explanation nobody asked for it
nobody butchering it nobody
asked for that my bad not what i meant
not what i meant at all and listen joe
rowling's a very close friend
very very close friend
do you think i'm that stupid yes yes
yes i'm sorry the answer is yeah now
you're asking an open-ended question
right so we were allowed to answer it
yes i think you're that stupid
i think you are one of the dumbest
people
that has been ever that's ever had a
microphone put in front of them
sure you're a mediocre fighter i would
have accepted brendan shaw the fighter
who you know mediocre
fighter who knocked some people out but
then he started sucking i would have
accepted that
and you know what would have never
judged if you would have kept
coming on rogan to talk about fights you
guys are friends right you could talk
about mma stuff nobody would have cared
but see what happened was you tried to
get into something that people worked
there [ __ ] and even rogan by the way
rogan's huge
rogan had to work these stand-up clubs
too you know what i mean like
he actually had to put the time in and
then he was given a show
or you know uh cast on a show he had to
put work in
you come in done nothing but a [ __ ]
mediocre fighter
do you understand people have have had
your careers and then they're starving
now because they don't have any more
money and they have really no other
discernible skills
you are the world's first cte
comic and it's not funny anymore people
are laughing at you brendan
you're not there's nothing you should
forget having one you shouldn't have
three podcast
you should have no podcast right now you
should be sitting down with a microphone
in your hand
doing one of those you want local local
mma announcing
and then maybe work your way up into
something bigger yeah you know it is
you you're right man he's just
how does you're not interesting enough
to have three podcasts a week like
that's insane to me it's ridiculous to
me that you don't you you're not
what do you bring let's say he wish you
know it
i would do it i would announce it to the
world like that to millions of people
give me a little i know i'm a dumb more
credit than that no
no because you don't deserve it brendan
because you
are that dumb he's saying give me more
credit
than what i actually don't judge me on
the thing i did
do you think i'm dumb enough to do the
thing you actually saw me do yes
yeah i saw you do it you did it please i
know
the people that defend these idiots are
to me are the worst kind like
no amount of us because these are the
comments we get from the [ __ ] little
rogan sick of fans
no amount of us being fat losers changes
the fact that this man is a
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah like forget us you
could criticize us all you want and
that's fine
no amount of us being [ __ ] doing in
your mouth
losers whatever dumb [ __ ] you guys say
changes the fact that this man's a
[ __ ] idiot and rogan surrounds
himself
with [ __ ] idiots yeah this is uh
you know i might still be fat tomorrow
but he's also gonna still be very stupid
you're still out of hot water yeah
tomorrow i might wake up and i will
definitely still be fat but you have to
still be brendan shaw and that honestly
is way worse
way worse to me should we play give me a
little more credit than that right let's
try and be funny
play the other clip real quick of course
yeah sorry because we want to i want to
clarify because maybe he's right
and maybe rogan and that crew they do
use sling and dick maybe in a way that
means just got it okay so this is uh
this is uh him with uh jim norton
this is the jim norton uh joe rogan
experience episode
[Music]
get started get started
boom and we're live let's have a toast
to hugh hefner
yes we lost one of the great dick
slingers of the 20th century
so i thought so what he meant was that
he was very successful and
you haven't had a podcast yeah i'm sure
that's what he's going to explain he did
he lost him
he literally had a place where guys
could go to be leches
yeah you could just go and you had a
mansion where everybody knew there was
going to be a bunch of
that's why they went yeah they went
there on purpose and there was guys that
like were notorious
for hanging around the mansion for going
to all the mansion parties like
did you ever go i went twice i went once
for a marijuana policy project
um thing i think that was a company that
was putting it together
uh where i hosted something and there's
bands and stuff like that was kind of
interesting that's fun
and then the other time i went was for
fear factor we did something for fear
factor with the playboy
playmates do you get to meet hugh i
never met a man
no no that's pretty much this yeah so
yeah but i just wanted to show that well
i i watched a little bit more it was
just funny because you get
in a second here it gets too chips
wasn't invited
like you didn't have enough credits yeah
they didn't like him so they just didn't
let him in
yeah he didn't have enough credits that
they actually rate you on and then joe
rogan asked him how long ago was this
two years ago when he was writing for
leno still maybe not a little
before that but still he written for
leno